you wrote a post about levels of
lucidity
quote as we grow older it becomes
apparent that our self-reflexive mind is
not just gradually accumulating ideas
about itself but that it progresses in
somewhat distinct stages
so there's seven of the stages stage one
reactive survival infant stage two
personal self young child stage three
social self adolescence domesticated
adult stage four is rational agency
self-direction stage five is self
authoring that's full adult you've
achieved wisdom but there's two more
stages stage six is Enlightenment stage
seven is Transcendence can you explain
each
or the interesting parts of each of
these stages and what's your sense why
there are stages
of this uh of Lucidity as we progress
through life in this too short life this
model is derived from concept by the
psychologist Robert Keegan and he talks
about the development of the self as a
process that happens in principle by
some kind of reverse engineering of a
mind where you gradually become aware of
yourself and thereby build structure
that allows you to interact deeper with
the world and yourself
and I found myself using this model not
so much as a developmental model I'm not
even sure if it's a very good
developmental model because I saw my
children not progressing exactly like
that and I also suspect that you don't
go to these stages necessarily in
succession and it's not that you work
through one stage and then you get into
the next one sometimes you revisit them
sometimes stuff is happening in parallel
but it's I think a useful framework to
look at what's present in the structure
of a person and how they interact with
the world and how they relate to
themselves
so it's more like a philosophical
framework that allows you to talk about
how mines work and at first when we are
born we don't have a personal self yet I
think instead we have an intentional
self and this attention itself is
initially in the infant task that's
building a world model and also an
initial model of the staff but mostly
it's building a game engine in the brain
that is tracking sensory data and uses
it to explain it and in some sense you
could compare it to game engine like
Minecraft or so-so colors and sounds
people are all not physical objects they
are creation of our mind at a certain
level of core screening models that are
mathematical that use geometry and that
use manipulation of objects and so on to
create scenes in which we can find
ourselves and interact with them so
Minecraft yeah and this personal self is
something that is more or less created
after the world is finished after it's
trained into the system after it has
been constructed and this personal self
is an agent that interacts with the
outside world and the outside world is
not the world of quantum mechanics the
not the physical universe but it's the
model that has been generated in our own
mind
right and this is us and we experience
ourselves interacting with stead outside
world that is created inside of our own
mind and outside of our self there's
feelings and then they presented our
interface to this outside world they
pose problems to us these feelings are
basically attitudes that our mind is
Computing that tell us what's needed in
the world the things that we are drawn
to or the things that we are afraid of
and we are tasked with solving this
problem of satisfying the needs avoiding
the aversions following on our inner
commitments and so on and also modeling
ourselves and building the next stage so
after we have this personal self in
stage two online many people form a
social self and this social self allows
the individual to experience themselves
as part of a group
it's basically this thing that when you
are playing in a team for instance you
don't notice yourself just as a single
note that is reaching out into the world
but you're also looking down you're
looking down from this entire group and
you see how this group is looking at
this individual and everybody in the
group is in some sense emulating this
group Spirit to some degree and in this
state people are forming their opinions
by assimilating them from this group
mind obviously gain the ability to act a
little bit like a hive mind body are you
also modeling the interaction of how
opinions shapes and forms through the
interaction of the individual nodes
within the group
yeah it's basically the way in which
people do it in this stage is that they
experience what are the opinions of my
environment they experience the
relationship that they have to their
environment and they resonate with
people around them and get moral
opinions in this through this
interaction to
um the way in which they relate to
others and at stage four you basically
understand that stuff is true and false
independently but other people believe
when you have agency over your own
beliefs in that stage you basically
discover epistemology the rules about
determining what's true and false so you
can you start to learn how to think
yes I mean at some level you're always
thinking you are constructing things and
I believe that this ability to reason
about your mental representation is what
we mean by thinking it's an
intrinsically reflexive process that
requires Consciousness without
Consciousness you cannot think you can
generate the content of feelings and so
on outside of Consciousness it's very
hard to be conscious of how your
feelings emerge at least in the early
stages of development but um thoughts is
something that you always control
and if you are a nerd like me
you often have to skip stage three
because you'd like the intuitive empathy
with others because in order to resonate
with a group you need to have a quite
similar architecture and if people are
wired differently then it's hard for
them to resonate with other people and
basically have empathy which is not the
same as compassion but it is a shared
perceptual mental state empathy happens
not just via inference about the major
states of others but it's a perception
of what other people feel and where
they're at can't you not have empathy
while also not having a similar
architecture cognitive architecture as
the others in the group I think yes but
I experience that too but you need to
build something that is like a meta
architecture you need to be able to
embrace the architecture of the other to
some degree also find some common ground
and it's also this issue that if you are
a nerd Nomis often some people is the
neurotypical people have difficulty to
resonate with you and as a result they
have difficult the understanding you
unless they have enough wisdom to to
fear what's going on there well aren't
we in the whole process of the stage
there is to figure out the API to the
other humans that have different
architecture and you yourself publish
public documentation for the API
that that people can interact with for
you isn't this the whole process of
socializing my experience as a child
growing up was that um I did not find
any way to interface with the stage
three people and they didn't do that
with me so probably right yeah of course
they tried it very hard but it was only
when I entered the mathematics school at
ninth grade lots of other nerds were
present
um that I found people that I could
deeply resonate with and had the
impression that yes I have the friends
now I found my own people and before
that I felt extremely lonely in the
world there was basically nobody I could
connect to
and
I remember
um there was one moment in all these
years where I was in there was a school
exchange and it was the Russian boy kid
from the Russian garnison station in
Eastern Germany you visit our school and
we played a game of chess against each
other and we looked into each other's
eyes and we sat there for two hours
playing this game of chess and I had the
impression this is a human being he
understands but I understand
we didn't even speak the same language
I wonder if uh your life could have been
different if you knew that it's okay to
be different to have a different
architecture
whether like accepting that
the interface is hard to figure out it
takes a long time to figure out and it's
okay to be different in fact it's
beautiful to be different
it was not my main concern my main
concern was mostly that it was alone
right this was not so much the question
is it okay to be the way I am the I
couldn't do much about it so I have to
do I have to deal with it but um my main
issue was that I was not sure if I would
ever meet anybody growing up
that I would connect to at such a deep
level that I would feel that I could
belong so there's a visceral undeniable
feeling of being alone yes and I noticed
the same thing when I came into the math
school that I think
at least half probably two-thirds of
these kids were severely traumatized as
uh children growing up and in large part
due to being alone
because they couldn't find anybody to
relate to don't you think everybody's
alone deep down no
huh
I'm not alone anymore it took me some
time to update and to get over the
traumata and so on but I felt that in my
20s I had lots of friends and I had my
place in the world and it was I had no
longer doubts that
I would never be alone again
is there some aspect to which We're
Alone Together you don't see a deep
loneliness inside yourself still no
sorry
okay so that's the non-linear
progression through the stages I suppose
you caught up on stage three it's stage
four and so basically I find that many
Nerds jump straight into stage four
bypassing stage three did they return to
it then later yeah of course sometimes
they do not always
yeah the question is basically do you
stay a little bit Autistic or do you
catch up and I believe you can catch up
you can build this missing structure
yeah and
um I basically experience yourself as
part of a group learn intuitive empathy
and develop the sense this percept
perceptual sense of feeling what other
people fear and before that I could only
basically feel this when I was deeply in
love with somebody and visitor so
there's a lot of friction to feeling
that way like it takes it only with
certain people as opposed to It comes
naturally yeah it's frictionless but um
this is something that basically later I
felt started to resolve itself for me to
a large degree what was the trick
in many ways growing up and paying
attention
meditation the top I had some very
crucial experiences
um in getting close to people building
connections
um
cuddling a lot in my student years
so really paying attention yeah to the
what is it to this
feeling another human being fully loving
other people and being loved by other
people and so building a space in which
you can be safe and can experiment and
um touch a lot and be close to somebody
a lot and over that over time basically
at some point you realize oh it's no
longer that I feel locked out but I feel
connected and I experience where
somebody else is at and normally my mind
is racing very fast at high frequency so
it's not always working like this
sometimes works better sometimes it
works less but also don't see this as a
pressure it's more it's interesting to
observe myself which frequency I'm at
and uh which mode somebody else has had
yeah man the mind is so beautiful in
that way it sometimes sometimes it comes
so natural to me so easy to pay
attention pay attention to the world
fool each other people fully and
sometimes the stress
over silly things is overwhelming it's
so interesting that demise that roller
coaster in that way and stage five
you'll discover how identity is
constructed self-offering realize that
your values are not terminal but they
are instrumental to achieving a world
that you like and Aesthetics that you
prefer yeah and um the more you
understand this the more you get agency
over how your identity is constructed
and you realize that identity in
interpersonal interaction is a costume
and you should be able to have agency
over that costume right it's useful to
be a costume it tells something to
others and that allows to interface in
roles but being locked into this is a
big limitation the word costume kind of
implies that it's fraudulent in some way
his costume a good word for you like to
present ourselves to the world in some
sense I learned a lot about costumes at
Burning Man before that I did not really
appreciate costumes and saw them more as
uniforms like wearing a suit if you are
working in a bank or if you are trying
to get startup funding for uh from a VC
in Switzerland right then you dress up
in a particular way and this is mostly
to show the other side that you are
willing to play by the rules and you
understand what the rules are but um
there is something deeper when you write
Burning Man your costume becomes
self-expression and there is no boundary
to the self-expression you're basically
free to wear what you want to express
other people what you feel like this day
and uh what kind of interactions you
want to have is the customer kind of
projection
of uh of Who You Are
that's very hard to say because the
costume also depends on what other
people see in the costume and this
depends on the context that the other
people understand and you have to create
something if you want to that is legible
to the other side and that means
something to yourself
do we become prisoners of the costume
because everybody expects us some people
do but um I think that once you realize
that you we are costume at Burning Man a
variety of costumes realize that you
cannot not wear a costume yeah right
basically everything that you wear and
present to others is something that is
to some degree in addition to what you
are deep inside so this stage in
parentheses you put full adult Karma
wisdom why is this full adult
why would you say this is full
and why is it wisdom it does allow you
to understand
um why other people have different
identities from yours and it allows you
to understand that the difference
between people who vote for different
parties and might have very different
opinions and different value systems is
often the accident of where they are
born and what happened after them after
that to them and what traits they got
before they were born and at some point
you realize the perspective where you
understand that everybody could be you
in a different timeline if you just flip
those bits
how many costumes do you have
I don't count but in more than one yeah
of course
how easy is to do costume changes
throughout the day
it's just a matter of energy and
interest when you are wearing your
pajamas and you switch out of your
pajamas into say a work short and pants
you're making a costume change right and
if you are putting on a gown you're
making a costume change you could do the
same with personality
you could if if that's what you're into
there are people which have multiple
personalities for interaction in
multiple worlds right so if somebody
works in a store and you put up a
storekeeper personality when you're
working when you're presenting yourself
at work you develop a step personality
for this and the social persona for many
people is in some sense a puppet that
they are playing like a marionette and
if they play this all the time they
might forget that there is something
behind this this is something what it
feels like to be in your skin and I
guess it's very helpful if you're able
to get back into this and for me it's
the other way around is relatively hard
for me it's pretty hard to learn how to
play consistent social roles for me it's
much easier just to be real
or not real but to have
a one costume
no it's not quite the same so basically
when you are wearing a costume at
Burning Man and say you are an
extraterrestrial Prince
um there's something where you are
expressing in some sense something is
closer to yourself than the way in which
you hide yourself behind a standard
closing when you go out in the city in
the default world and so this costume
that you're wearing at Burning Man
allows you to express more of yourself
and uh you have a shorter distance of
advertising to people
what kind of person you are what kind of
interaction you would want to have with
them and so you get much earlier into
media Express and I believe it's
regrettable that we do not use the
opportunities that we have this
custom-made closing now to wear costumes
that are much more stylish that are much
more custom-made that are not
necessarily part of a fashion in which
you express which milieu you're part of
and how up to date you are but you also
Express
how you are as an individual and what
you want to do today and how you feel
today and what you intend to do about it
well isn't it easier now with in the
digital world
to uh
to explore different costumes I mean
that's the kind of idea with virtual
reality that's the idea even with
Twitter in two-dimensional screens you
can you can swap all costumes you can be
as weird as you want it's easier for
burning man you have to like order
things you have to make things you have
to it's more effort to it's better if
you make them yourselves
sure but it's just easier to do
digitally right it's not about easy it's
about how to get it right and for me the
first Burning Man experience I got
adopted by a bunch of people in Boston
who dragged me to Burning Man and we
spent a few weekends doing costumes
together and that was an important part
of the experience where the camp bonded
that people got to know each other and
we basically grew into the experience
that we would have later so the
Extraterrestrial Prince is based on a
true story yeah
[Music]
I can only imagine what that looks like
yosha okay stage six stage six
um at some point you can collapse the
division between self and personal stuff
and world generator again
and a lot of people get there via
meditation or some of them get their via
psychedelics some of them by accident
and you suddenly noticed that you are
not actually a person but you are a
vessel that can create a person
and the person is still there You
observe that personal self But You
observe the personal self from the
outside
and you notice it's a representation and
you might also notice that the word that
is being created is a representation if
not then you might experience that I am
the Universe I am the thing that is
creating everything and of course what
you're creating is not quantum mechanics
and the physical Universe what you're
creating is the scheme engine that is
updating the world and you are creating
your valence your feelings your uh and
all the people inside of that world
including the person that you identify
with yourself and as well are you
creating the game engine or are you
noticing the game imagine
um you noticed how you're generating the
game engine
and I mean when you are dreaming at
night you can uh if you lose have a
lucid dream you can learn how to do this
deliberately and in principle you can
also do it during the day and the reason
why we don't get to do this from the
beginning and why we don't have agency
of our feelings right away is because we
would game it before they have the
necessary amount of wisdom to uh to deal
with creating this dream that we are in
you know you don't want to get access to
cheat codes too quickly otherwise you
won't enjoy so stage five is already
pretty rare and Stage six is even more
rare you post basically find this mostly
this Advanced Buddhist meditators and so
on that uh dropping into this stage and
can induce it at will and spend time in
it so stage five acquires a good
therapist stage six requires a good uh
Buddhist
spiritual leader it is for instance
could be that is the right thing to do
but it's not that these stages give you
scores or levels that you need to
advance to it's not that the next stage
is better you live your life in in the
motto it works best at any given moment
and when your mind decides that you
should uh have a different configuration
then it's building that configuration
and for many people they stay happily at
stage three and experiences themselves
as part of groups and there's nothing
wrong with this and for some people this
doesn't work and they're forced to build
more agency over their rational beliefs
than this and construct their Norms
rationally and so they go to this level
and Stage seven is something that is
more or less hypothetical that would be
the stage in which it's basically a
transhuman stage in which you understand
how you work and which the Mind fully
realizes how it's implemented and can
also in principle enter different modes
in which it could be implemented and
that's the stage that as as far as I
understand is not open to people yet
oh but it is possible to the process of
Technology yes and who knows if there
are biological agents that are working
at different time skills than us that
basically become aware of the way in
which they are implemented on ecosystems
and can change that implementation and
have agency over how they implemented in
the world and what I find interesting
about the discussion about AI alignment
that it seems to be following these
status very much most people seem to be
in stage three also according to Robert
Keegan I think he says that about 85
percent of people are in stage three and
stay there and if you're in stage fear
for a three and your opinions are the
result of social assimilation then what
you're mostly worried about and the AI
is that the AI might have the wrong
opinions so if the AI is just something
racist or sexist we are all lost because
we will assimilate the wrong opinions
from the AI and so we need to make sure
that the AI has the right opinions and
the right values and the right structure
and
and if you're at stage four that's not
your main concern and so most nerds I
don't really worry about
um the algorithmic bias and the model
that it picks up because if there's
something wrong with this bias the AI
ultimately will prove it at some point
we'll get it there that it makes
mathematical proofs about reality and
then it will figure out what's true and
what's false but you're still worried
that AI might turn you into paper clips
because it might have the wrong values
right so if it's set up is there a wrong
function that controls its direction in
the world then it might do something
that is completely horrible and has no
easy way to fix it so that's more like a
stage four rationalist kind of worry and
if you are at stage five you're mostly
worried that AI is not going to be
indicted fast enough because you realize
that the game is not so much about
intelligence but about agency about the
ability to control the future and the
identity is instrumental to this and if
you are Are a Human Being I think at
some level you ought to choose your own
identity it's you should not have
somebody else pick the costume for you
and then wear it but instead you should
be mindful about what you want to be in
as well and I think if you are an agent
that is fully malleable that can rewrite
its own source code like an AI might do
at some point then the identity that you
will have is whatever you can be
and in this way the AI will maybe become
everything like a planetary control
system and if it does that then if we
want to coexist with it it means that it
will have to share purposes with us so
it cannot be a transactional
relationship we will not be able to use
reinforcement learning with human
feedback to hardwire its values into it
but this has to happen it's probably
that it's conscious so it can relate to
our own mode of existence where an
observer is observing itself in real
time and there's a certain temporal
frames and the other thing is that it
probably needs to have some kind of
transcendental orientation building
shared agency and in the same way as we
do when we are able to enter with each
other and to a non-transactional
relationships and I find that something
that because the Stage 5 is so rare is
is missing in much of the discourse and
I think that we need in some sense
focus on how to formalize love how to
understand love and how to build it into
the machines that we are currently
building and that are about to become
smarter than us